you're a girl right  I'd like to think of myself as a woman  veno things okay you're a woman young  woman all right you're young woman now I  got this girl and I know she likes me  and I like her but how can you tell if  when she says no does she really mean  maybe or did she really mean no  you mean like no like she doesn't want  to go out with you anymore  no you know what I'm talking about well  how long you known her well we went out  on our first date last week you've had  one date with every uh-huh  one day uh-huh Vito what a girl really  wants is for you to want to get to know  her find out you know what goes through  her head you know give it some time you  know  I'll give it two more days do it no  that's not what I meant